[Música]
nuevas medidas contra el hobbit 19 en
eeuu debido al avance de la variante
delta en el país más de 4 millones de
trabajadores del gobierno federal
deberán mostrar una prueba de vacunación
contra el cubit 19 2 someterse a pruebas
de manera regular
además yobái le pedirá al pentágono que
añada la de kobe 19 a la lista de
vacunas obligatorias para los militares
estadounidenses miles de guatemaltecos
exigieron la dimisión del presidente
alejandro giammatei y de la fiscal
general en una jornada de marchas y
bloqueos esto tras el despido del jefe
de la fiscalía especial contra la
impunidad considerado una figura clave
en la lucha contra la corrupción en el
país
hoy 29 de julio es el día de sobregiro
de la tierra la humanidad ya consumió
todos los recursos naturales que el
planeta puede regenerar en un año
incluso algunos países están
sobregirados desde hace meses chile por
ejemplo está en deuda desde el 17 de
mayo
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france24 blanco como
siempre un gusto saludarlos iniciamos en
eeuu donde los más de 4 millones de
trabajadores del gobierno federal
deberán mostrar una prueba de vacunación
contra kobe 19 o de lo contrario
someterse a pruebas de manera regular
esto ante el avance de la variante delta
que ha impulsado el aumento de contagios
y hospitalizaciones particularmente
entre los no vacunados además el
presidente de eeuu joe biden también
pedirá al pentágono que añada la del coi
19 a la lista de vacunas obligatorias
para los militares estadounidenses
desplegados en todo el mundo
bailén también propuso incentivos de 100
dólares a quienes se vacuna a cada uno
de los empleados federales tendrá que
dar fe de su estado de vacunación
a quienes no los certifique no quieren
no estén vacunados estarán en la
obligación de llevar tapabocas sin
importar donde trabajen
y hacerse pruebas una o dos veces por
semana para ver si han contraído el
virus mantener el distanciamiento social
y en general no les era permitido
desplazarse para ir al trabajo
para hablar sobre el anuncio del
presidente joe biden de la vacunación
obligatoria para empleados federales
quiero saludar en este momento a césar
grajales director nacional de asuntos
públicos de libre iniciar y gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24 le
pregunto señor grajales si puede el
gobierno de un país en este caso el de
eeuu a obligar a sus empleados a tomar
una medicina una vacuna como recibe
usted estos anuncios del presidente
ballena
bueno varias cosas primero que todo hay
que recordar que estamos hablando de
empleados federales en este aspecto pues
como si como si fueran en una empresa
privada por este caso el gobierno pues
tiene lineamientos y reglamentos con sus
empleados y tiene la potestad a
requerirle a los empleados algo que
consideran que es importante para el
desarrollo de su trabajo y para mantener
a los los trabajadores
pues saludables en este aspecto estamos
hablando más que de una medicina pues de
una vacuna que es algo preventivo lo
interesante de todo este tema es que yo
creo que ambos partidos han anunciado
muchísimo el tema de la vacuna el tema
de la pandemia y entonces se ha creado
esta situación donde hay un montón de
gente que no se quiere vacunar porque
tiene miedo y tiene dudas porque quizá
no entiende el proceso de la vacuna como
fue hecha pero hay varias cosas
importantes que resaltar muchas veces
tomamos medicinas o medicamentos o
vacunas que han usado un muestreo
muchísimo más menor del que ya hay en
este momento recordemos que
originalmente para que fuera aprobada la
vacuna como algo este de emergencia fue
corto pero ahora ya hay más de hay
cientos de millones de personas
alrededor del mundo que ya se vacunaron
y deberían de tener este temor
ahora han cesar crearán estas medidas a
mayor división política y polarización
entre demócratas y republicanos que
tienen visiones muy distintas de la
importancia de la vacunación en este
caso contra kobe 19 rápidamente por
favor sí bueno yo creo que espero que no
pero obviamente reitero esto lo han
politizado a ambos lados tristemente el
día de hoy por primera vez el presidente
reconoció que la administración pasada
encabezada por el partido republicano
son los que desarrollaron la vacuna él
mismo lo dijo hoy y que ellos ahora en
la administración siendo control de
demócratas en la cámara y la cámara
casablanca son los que están
administrando estas vacunas yo creo que
ahorita lo importante es que la gente
entienda que es importante vacunarse
césar gracias por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros en france 24 face resto de
noche miles de guatemaltecos salieron a
las calles en todo el país para exigir
la renuncia del presidente alejandro
giammatei y de la fiscal general tras el
despido de un conocido fiscal
anticorrupción las protestas cobraron
fuerza desde que la fiscal general de
guatemala consuelo porras instituyó la
semana pasa
a juan francisco sandoval quien era el
jefe de la fiscalía especial contra la
impunidad una medida que provocó que
washington se pusiera suspendiera la
colaboración con el ministerio público
guatemalteco el gobierno descaradamente
se ha equipado la careta de de estar a
favor de la justicia y sacan al último
baluarte que está peleando en contra de
la impunidad en guatemala significa
entonces que estamos en manos de la
misma
hoy es 29 de julio y nos quedan ya 5
meses hasta el final de este año pero la
humanidad ya ha consumido más recursos
naturales de lo que el planeta puede
regenerar en un año la herramienta
utilizada para calcular este llamado día
de sobregiro fue creada porque dada en
los años 90 por una ong estadounidense
pero hoy su metodología está puesta en
duda veamos por qué
es un indicador del que oímos hablar
todos los años el día del sobregiro
marca el día en que la humanidad agota
todos los recursos naturales que la
tierra puede generar anualmente durante
los últimos 30 años esta fecha no ha
dejado de acelerarse salvo por una pausa
temporal al inicio de la pandemia de
cody 19 el año pasado en 1990 el día de
sobregiro cayó el 10 de octubre pero
este año estaremos viviendo a crédito
desde el 29 de julio según la red global
footprint el día del sobregiro se
calcula dividiendo la biocapacidad del
planeta por la huella ecológica de la
humanidad sin embargo esta metodología
está puesta en duda por los científicos
afirman que el cálculo no toma en cuenta
los recursos minerales ni los espacios
necesarios para la biodiversidad ni
siquiera los residuos plásticos
en el cálculo de la huella ecológica se
tiene en cuenta la capacidad de
absorción de residuos pero el único
residuo que se tiene en cuenta es en co2
y hay otros residuos que se producen
y los expertos también advierten que
centrarse en el mundo en su conjunto y
no en países concretos diluye la
gravedad del problema este mapa muestra
en rojo los países que consumen en
exceso los recursos naturales los que
están en verde tienen una reserva de
biocapacidad pero son pocos a pesar de
sus imperfecciones científicas el día
del sobregiro sigue cumpliendo su
objetivo alertar al público sobre la
importancia de salvar los recursos
naturales de la tierra
en francia ha surgido una nueva polémica
en torno al paso sanitario que entrará
en vigor el próximo 9 de agosto en esta
ocasión son los franceses en el
extranjero quienes se quejan de los
problemas que tendrán para homologar las
vacunas no aceptadas por la unión
europea el gobierno había prometido un
plan de vacunación para expatriados que
afirman no se ha cumplido rodrigo se da
no tiene más detalles
la vacunación contra el kobe 19 se está
tornando en un problema para los
franceses que están en el exterior
muchos tienen ya la pauta completa en
sus países de residencia pero sus
vacunas no son reconocidas por la
agencia europea del medicamento el
gobierno francés había prometido una
estrategia para inocular a los
expatriados con vacunas homologadas pero
la estrategia no ha llegado a si lo
hacía saber al gobierno la senadora de
los republicanos severin ganó garabedian
el pasado 13 de julio
en enero de 2021 había sido anunciado un
plan de vacunación para los franceses en
el extranjero sin embargo francia no
enviado las dosis a los países en los
que no se ha comenzado una vacunación
con vacunas homologadas por ejemplo
argentina que vacuna con sputnik y
scinopharm
ha sido el mayor problema llegará en
agosto con la aplicación del pase
sanitario que instaurará un qr para las
personas vacunadas en francia o en otros
países de la unión europea para los casi
3 millones de expatriados por el momento
no hay solución para conseguir ese qr si
no han sido inmunizados con las vacunas
aceptadas
la agencia europea del medicamento la
propuesta para algunos debería pasar por
ampliar el reconocimiento de vacunas
la aplicación del pase sanitario debe
incluir completamente a los franceses en
el extranjero gobierno de francia es
hora de actuar para que francia
reconozca por completo las vacunas
aprobadas por la oms por el momento el
gobierno de manuel macro no ha dado una
respuesta a este caso y de esta manera
llegamos al final del informativo en
france24 continúa con nosotros para más
actualizaciones de noticias
[Música]